I want to follow up on a story from
yesterday yesterday I told you that
another black man died unarmed allegedly
after police shot him in California many
people looked at the picture that is
over my shoulder and we can actually put
up full screen for our audience that is
watching people looking at this picture
and saying well if you look at the guy
there
in the black shirt he looks like he's in
what some would describe as a shooting
stance so he might have had a firearm he
might not have had a firearm we don't
really know but what officers did is
completely defensible because he looks
like he would be holding a firearm now
you'll notice this picture was taken
from very far away one of those officers
seems to be about eight feet away from
this individual so that certainly would
be a concern you would think that
Officer would know what it was that
thirty-eight-year-old
at Alfred Elango had in his hand so I'll
show you some of the responses we
received yesterday when we initially did
this story we'll put those up on the
screen for people watching with us
this man was mentally challenged he was
mimicking the police because he didn't
know any better and the sister told the
cops that when she called them it was to
help her brother
another comment said I don't understand
why people just don't listen to police
orders another comment he put his hands
out as if he had a firearm when a person
does some s like that to the police the
odds are high of getting shot maybe the
problem is so many black people are
showing willful ignorance and or the
media only wants to cover black people
being shot by cops
another comment a stance like that is
not negotiable I would shoot him and
lastly I can almost guarantee you're
wrong
referring to me David about the fact
that this was an allegedly unarmed man
well the police have spoken and they've
confirmed that indeed Alfred Elango had
a vape smoking device in his hand
not a gun yes he pointed his smoking
device at police and police shot and
tasered him at the same time killing him
and this is really the point I want to
make to you here people are emailing me
saying David doesn't matter what Al
verda Lango had in his hand he was in a
shooting stance period police instantly
have to go on the defensive and use of
force including deadly force including
what was in this case shooting and
tasering this man leading to his death
at the same time they had no choice but
to do that I think that that comment is
hugely disrespectful to police if what
you're saying is police can be no better
trained then if anyone goes like this
you shoot them dead even if you're eight
feet away I actually find that insulting
and I know police officers who if you
told them listen you're completely
justified in shooting anyone who from
eight feet away goes like this holding
here's a pen this is effectively what he
was holding a vaping device a vape
cigarette like that you're justified in
shooting that person I know police
officers who would say wait a second no
no no my training is better than that I
don't from eight feet away mistake a
vape smoking device with a gun that
could kill me so if that's your argument
you are completely under estimating the
skill of many police in this country not
all we know from the countless stories
that we see that many police officers
will take the opportunity either out of
fear or out of malice or whatever it may
be where when they have an e-cig or a
vaping device pointed at them from eight
feet away they'll say this person now
deserves to die most police officers
would disagree with you and they would
say no no no no we're better trained
than to shoot anyone who holds up an
e-cigarette and I absolutely ridiculous
that the defense is from eight feet away
east cigarette stuffed animal firearm
hot dog it's all the same if you hold it
like this you're getting killed by
police despicable and absolutely
disgusting